On our call, we discussed the Dutch test for horrible, the Dutch test, which one do you suggest me to order the Dutch plus or the Dutch complete.
Also, you took me off the iodide on the breast, but do I need to be taking some, do I need to be taking it internally for the thyroid currently I'm not at any other iodide supplement.
So the first question, what should you do if you're going to do the Dutch test, should you do the Dutch test plus this one here, or should you do the Dutch test complete.
The Dutch complete is the one I typically recommend the plus adds some organic acid tests, but it's not a complete organic acid test.
So I would just say just do the complete the cheaper one the 325.
What I have everybody do is the complete, it's the organic acid test that's included in this doesn't have enough tests for me to justify adding the $100.
We're going to do an organic acid test and do a full organic acid test around great planes.
So that's that first question, do the complete the cheaper one the less expensive one.
You took me off the iodide on the breast, yes, I did, but do I need to be taking it internally for the thyroid.
Well, should anybody be taking thought iodide for the thyroid, well, what you're going to find is all the new information.
This course right here module six I lay out in great detail why no one should be taking iodine.
At all, the only time you should be taking iodine is for a short period time for breast cancer, but nobody else should be taking iodine nobody should be taking iodine.
For their thyroid plant and I will go into any greater detail on that and I know some of you who have been in functional medicine for a while go what they make sense.
Of course, everybody needs iodine.
Yes, you need iodine to make tea three, but you need such a little amount you should not be taking any exogenous iodine immediately any supplemental iodine at all zero done so don't be taking iodine.
If you want a more information on that quarter module six other on the automobile course.
Sure, they have not any other iodine to help, but that's exactly right. That's what I wanted.